- Good morning Believe
Nation, today's message is
work the hardest.
Over to you Wayne Gretzky.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
♫ I wake up every morning ♫
- [Wayne] Professional
sports isn't much different
than the real world.
The players who love it
the most, and the players
who work the hardest.
The players who put in
the biggest commitment
they're the ones who ultimately
are successful as athletes.
And then when they go into
the real world, the business
world, those are the athletes
who become successful
in a whole different venture.
So, there's a very similar
sort of mindset to whatever it is,
and the good lord blessed me.
I was fortunate enough
to play in the National
Hockey League.
Why I was chosen, I don't know.
When you focus all your
attention on being the best
player you can become.
And that's a full-time job.
I mean, you don't have time to think about
life after hockey, life during hockey.
If you want to be the
best athlete you can be
your focus is just doing that
and playing the game of hockey.
- The people who win work the hardest
because they love what they do.
They put in the hours and
the hours and the hours
and the hours for days and days and days
and weeks and weeks and weeks
and months and months and months.
And years and years and years.
Because they love it.
Because it's not work for them.
The only way you're going
to be willing to put in
the work that is necessary to win,
to be the best in your industry
the only way you're going to
put in that amount of work
is because, you love what you're doing.
(gentle music)
And if you don't, you're going to lose.
'Cause there's going to be
somebody who will love it,
who loves it more than you
and will crush you.
And you'll be not even a
number two, you'll be mediocre
because there's lots of
people who love what they do.
And there's lots of people
grinding it and working hard.
If you are looking at your
calendar, like open up
your calendar, look what
you're going to do today
or look at what you're doing tomorrow.
What's on the schedule?
If you're looking at
it and you're like, ah,
I've got to do all these things.
If that's your reaction
you might be in the wrong business.
Now if it's a one-off
thing, if it's a one day
you got to deal with the government,
or it's something, fine.
But if that's daily, if that's consistent,
if that's always happening,
if you continue to look at
your calendar and you're
upset and depressed and angry
you're in the wrong business.
The work
should feel like something
exciting to go and do.
Where other people might
jump into your schedule
and say, "That's crazy.
"I could never do that."
That's great, that's why you're
not crushing it like I am.
Like, go crush it in your field.
Go do your thing.
As an example, here's
one change that I've made
to my YouTube channel.
You may have noticed this month
the video series looked
a little bit different.
I'm working with a videographer, Jason.
And the only way we can
make this thing work was
if we did it on one day.
So I used to film my videos once a week.
On a Wednesday, for the week.
And Jason works by the day, so,
"Okay, you know what, I
want to increase the quality
"of the videos.
"I want them to look more Hollywood."
Do we look more Hollywood?
Is it looking nice?
Do you guys like the quality?
Give a thumbs for Jason
down in the comments.
And the way to make it work
was to do it once a month.
And so, I'm sitting here filming my videos
for the month.
We're doing like 70 videos in one day.
Grinding them through.
I've got two extra large coffees.
I got one sitting behind here
I'm half way through that.
And here's a thing, to make this work
it's a lot of extra pressure on my team
to get a lot of things
ready and sooner and faster.
Right, so my team's
been working extra hard
to get it ready for this one time
and if we continue it,
it's their usual job.
It's not as stressful or hard.
I'm thinking about them.
I don't want them to stress out too much.
But really, the person who
has it the hardest is me.
Because for me, it's not just
a one-off thing.
This is now going to be every month.
Like, do I have the ability
to stay "on",
to have energy for an entire day?
Can I get through making 70 videos
in a single day?
I don't know.
But when Jason and I are
on email we're trying
to figure this out,
and I look at how hard it was going to be
for me to do, to be on
camera for that long.
I'm like, I got to do this.
This is awesome.
(laughs)
I might crash and burn and
like it doesn't work out
and it totally fails
and I can't handle the
the length and the
time, but I want to try.
Where so many people have
a hard time making one
to two videos a month.
Here, we are making 70 in a day.
Crushing it all down.
And I love it.
It's hardest on me versus
anybody else on my team.
But I'm not even thinking about it because
I love the challenge.
I love the ability to
work that hard and see
if I can do it.
And see if it makes sense
for what we're trying to do.
What do you guys think?
Do you like these videos lke this?
Do you want more of it?
Let me know, leave a comment.
And so, in thinking
about that I don't think
that I'm super special, by the way.
I just found the thing that I love doing.
I'm willing to put in this
kind of hustle and work
because I love making the videos,
because I want to create
more and better content
for you guys.
You could put in that same
amount of drive, energy,
hustle that I'm doing
today in your business.
But it's not going to happen
if you look at your schedule
and like, go like this.
I was looking at my schedule last night
and like, I'm so excited about tomorrow.
I'm so excited about tomorrow.
It's so good, I can see how it goes
try to crush it.
Right, and again
not every day is going
to be super amazing.
But you should love the
work that you do net net.
You should be excited about
the day that is ahead,
net net, and not feeling sad,
depressed, angry, frustrated
about the work that you have to do.
The people who win work
the hardest because
they love what they do.
So the question today I'm curious,
do you look forward to
the day that you have
tomorrow?
Look at your schedule tomorrow,
look at what's on the calendar.
Are you excited about that day?
I know it's just a snapshot
but I want to know for tomorrow,
are you excited and what's
the most interesting
and exciting thing that
you have on your list?
Leave it down in the comments below
and we'll join in the discussion.
I also want to give a
quick shout out to Chase.
Chase, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Year One Word.
It really really really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying it.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your year one word is
and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot
of Espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
♫ I wake up every morning ♫
- Hey Believe Nation, thank
you so much for watching.
If you want to learn
more about this subject,
get a little bit deeper on it
I'm going to share some extra bonus clips
that I hope you'll enjoy.
- You think there were
no hurdles or obstacles
that I had overcome but
even I got to high school I wasn't ranked.
I wasn't ranked, I wasn't highly touted
as a high school prospect.
I had nobody really
running, knocking on my door
saying, "Please please please come play
"for our school." until
Coach McKillip called.
Everything happens for
a reason and there's
a story to everything.
And if you take time
to realize what your dream is
and what you really want in
life, no matter what it is
whether it's sports, whether
it's in other fields.
You have to realize that
there's always work to do
and you want to be the
hardest working person
in whatever you do and you
put yourself in position
to be successful.
And you have to have a
passion about what you do.
And basketball was mine,
and that's what's carried
me through this point.
- The choice you have as an underdog is
if you're going to choose to fight
and choose to work to fight to win
there are a series of
strategies available to you.
But they are all more costly
than the strategies
available to the favorite.
So I give the example of a chapter about a
a software mogul in Silicone
Valley, an Indian guy
who coaches his daughters,
12-year-old daughter's
basketball team.
And they are, without talent.
They are, by his own admission,
this was like, they didn't
know how to play the game.
He takes them all the way to
that National Championships.
He does it by, he instructs them
they're going to play
the full court press.
Every minute of every game
and defend every inch of the court, right?
Now, that's actually a
very effective strategy
particularly in age glass basketball.
If you're the underdog
you're only chance at winning
is to play a really
aggressive league defense.
It requires, however
that everyone in your
team expend maximum effort
every minute of the game.
You cannot loaf for an instant.
You have to be in really good shape
and you have to run yourself ragged.
And you cannot let up.
Most people will not play that way
because it's too difficult.
If I said to you we're
not going to be doing
this elegantly designed plays
and shooting gorgeous baskets
and passing the ball.
We're just going to be doing
this for the entire game.
And you're going to be
exhausted at the end
most kids would say, "That's
not why I signed up."
So it's like that's a kind
of clasic illustration of
the effort,
effort is the route
one of the routes
available to the underdog.
I cannot work you if, I may not be able
to out spend you, but I can outwork you.
Well, outworking is
a tall order, it's not easy to do.
That's as anyone who is
worked in a start up knows
that's one of the stressful parts of it.
But successful startups
I've never seen any
actual data on this but
do we think that people working for
successful startups, work
longer hours than people
who work for Fortune 500 companies?
My guess is yes.
- It wasn't until I started my own team
when I realized that there are people
with incredible talent, and no motivation.
And then there are other
people that are willing
to work their ass off
who don't have a natural ability
but will become successful
because they're so determined.
And I saw,
I saw it especially in a couple of guys
that I first put on the Birdhouse team
namely Andrew Reynolds, and Matt Beach.
Matt Beach was,
in my eyes, the most naturally
talented skateboarder
that I'd ever seen.
Everything came easy in him
and when I would request
these guys to go on tour
all I ask of them is that they skate.
For exhibitions, and what not.
Matt wouldn't skate half the time.
I flew him to Europe.
I didn't even have any money then.
In our company, but I was
flying these guys to Europe
for competitions.
He would go to the (mumbling)
and not feel like skating.
And I was like, how can you do that?
I was just thinking, not
just to me but to yourself.
You have this incredible talent
and you just don't care.
And then I saw Andrew
Reynolds who was this
scrappy little guy taking not very clean
but, in terms of his style.
But trying some of the hardest stuff,
taking the heaviest hits
but always skating his (bleeped) off.
And always trying.
And he has become probably
the most well-respected
street skater today.
Andrew Reynolds, I mean,
he formed Bakerbrand,
Deathwish Skateboards.
The community of the most
hardcore skaters these days
call him The Boss.
Because he developed his style because
he worked his ass off.
And he's the shining example of hard work.